this week conflicts owners in Brussels
where we are meeting the Deputy Prime
Minister of Somalia Mohamed O'Mara at a
four-decade
Somalia has been the symbol of a failed
state one whose government is unable to
fulfill the most basic functions the
Somali government says things are
looking up but are they being honest
with themselves and the rest of the
world
Mohammed Omar Artur welcome to conflict
zone mr. Artur just three months ago in
a talk in London you said you are very
proud that Somalia is no longer a failed
state yet it remains in second place and
the fragile states index formerly known
in the failed states index of the fund
for peace only South Sudan is worse what
is that
you are proud of we were not even we
were not part of how shall I say any we
did there was no way that we they could
count on before that but now it is we
are on the second place South Sudan is
worse you are saying that you are not a
failed state this is interesting point
of view the point of view of of their
index yeah we're not a failed state
because we have come out of a failed
state situation and maybe 15 years four
years ago we were not even being
considered as as a fragile state but now
at least we are and there are certain
structures that have been put into place
for instance since for the last four
years we have now a proper budget proper
security instruct infrastructure we have
developed a state and you know the
member states are now functioning there
is governance in the fund for peace
report is documenting clearly human
rights worsened demographic pressures
worsened the security apparatus worsened
and even economic development worsened
and state legitimacy worsened and you
are actually still telling the public
that Somalia is making progress yes it
is two years ago there were one hundred
two hundred and thirty-four
recommendations made by the universal
periodical review we went back we have
you know done or you know we have
replied to most of them and on top of
that
when I look at the economic growth the
chromic Rose is for the first time has
been documented as growing at you know
four point three percent and it is also
documented that there is and you know
when we talk about these security that
has been in pointing out numbers some
more figures the United Nations
Development Program says you have a
seventy three percent poverty rate in
average life extensa C of fifty five
years and less than thirty two percent
of your adult population can read that
all sounds like a faith and not like a
stable State but let me tell you one
thing where have we come from 25 years
ago and where are we today we came from
25 years ago where there was a collapse
of the state itself now it is a real
it's a it's a state that is rebuilding
itself redeeming itself but would you
say it's a state would you say it's a
stable state or in this only in
relationship to the past a progress I
don't know how you okay but I would out
for instance as far as I'm concerned I
would say that we have a state and the
state is developing that is what that's
what I would say so let's continue to
talk about that more facts use
unemployment sixty-seven percent annual
per capita income of 450 euros frequent
murders of politicians and activists
this all sounds like a failed and not
like a stable state I mean frequent
murders of also politicians in as far as
targeted killings are concerned that is
something that a Shabaab does it is not
something that is done out of because of
lack of statehood but it is a targeted
you know group that is targeting
politicians to make sure that there is
no stability in the country so that is
how it is but I would out out disagree
with you on on the figures because the
figures also point out the negativity
part but why not take also the
positivity
we can do it positively youth
unemployment 67% or employment 33% third
of your young population has something
to work this is something compared to
what are you comparing them to you know
are you comparing them to Belgium for
instance if that is the case yes but if
you're comparing to the region we are
not doing as bad but we could do better
so this is it it all depends on let us
compare apples to apples and not apples
to oranges okay so now we compare
something with a quote of the foreign
minister of your country of the Sam or
mayor is on the record as saying I quote
we are working hard on stabilization but
for the Somalia government it is like
building a plane and flying at the same
time taking this metaphor seriously the
plane that your government built is
crashed it has crashed no it hasn't it
is still flying is going on for the 4th
for the last four years it has been
ongoing did we see a lot of change
positive changes in the country and I
and I know you know what he meant is
that there are a lot of problems
problems that we have phased a number
one and you know it's it's a matter of
capacity it's a matter of finances it's
a matter of security it's a matter of an
administration it's a matter of human
tear it all at one all all requiring our
attention we will do it piece by piece
but you mentioned security the truth is
your government only controls small
parts of your country you are the
government of Mogadishu not of Somalia
are you not mm-hmm we are in Mogadishu
and we operate out of Mogadishu however
however however we have our federal
Member States and it's our federal
states it wasn't there before now that
it is there do you control the whole
country militarily we do control through
our federal Member States and that's how
it is it is not necessarily that I have
to control them but it's a cookie
not speaking about you personally
controlling the area because we have to
talk a little a little bit about this
army Somalia officially has 22,000
standing troops unofficial estimates put
the real number as low as 10,000 it
appears that officers exaggerate the
numbers of soldiers in order to pocket
the surplus wages how long do you think
you can go on fooling yourself your
people in the international community
about your army and your security
standards okay let me tell let me tell
you one thing this is we talk about a
state that has collapsed a state that
went down the drain a state that is
coming out of of the ashes that is what
we what we're looking at you cannot
judge it in in a in a perfect situation
where you are looking at the state like
other other countries we have gone
through the worst what we're doing is
that we're trying to change this by
building up what financial systems by
building up by metrics we have already
have adjusted 18,000 biometric soldiers
in our biometric system we are now you
know developing a payroll system so it
is something that is developing and it's
not something that you know we cannot
talk about it and compare it to old it
is something that has been existing for
the last time there's some priorities
and one of the priority is the biggest
threat to Somalia the terrorist group us
about your presidents said recently that
the government must choose between
giving its soldier wages or weapons an
army that has less than half the numbers
of soldiers they claim to have with
commanders earning double the wages is a
threat to its own country it is
certainly not about the presence the
presence that you must choose between
giving its soldier wages more weapons
but you can't continue the way that it
is still now because the protection of
your borders is not guaranteed the
protection of your population is not any
more guaranteed by the country so but I
mean can you be more because I am kind
of look good do you believe that your
population is protected
if it is not protected how else would we
stop attacks that we are coming into
Mogadishu how else would we have been
able to stop those how else would we
have been you know able to prevent an
al-shabaab to continue to to commit the
atrocities that they have give your
answers you mentioned the questions how
are you doing that's what that's what
exactly we're doing we're doing it
through by preventing almost seven to
eight seven to ten attacks that were
eminent attacks that are going to happen
in Mogadishu
we have been preventing it for the last
12 aerial close about the last six
months and on a monthly basis we have
dismantled their intelligence their what
they call them yet we have worked on on
targeting them with through our our our
military and commandos so I think I
think we have we have done quite a
tremendous job when it comes to
preventing a Shabaab in continuing to do
the kind of there are other opinions
about that and that's why your own your
own Army's effort to defeat a Shabat are
backed by a 22,000 a strong African
peace keeping force called Amazon you
yourself have described Amazon in 2015
as static what did you mean by that
static static that's what you said
static not really helping not being
enough and efforts static I don't
remember that but in any case what we
what happened was that the operations
that we were that it was supposed to be
taking cocaine you know between Amazon
and SNA where at that time not moving
forward so now we have an ongoing
concept operations that is going to take
that's taking place right now in aerobic
where it would be defined and new and
offensive would soon start it seems that
al-shabaab is still the most decisive
power in your region neither your troops
know Amazon is capable of regaining
military power on your turrets
is it or is it it well it is improving
we gaining you know now they don't have
they don't control any areas a large
swath of areas most of the regions and
the dismay of districts are not in their
hand we have now regional
administration's that are in place in in
gal Moodle in southwest in Jubilees and
a scale from one to ten ten is the
highest one
what would you say where are you in
terms of in terms of protecting your
circulation six that's interesting but
is not just a threat to Somalia it is a
threat to your neighbors to earth or PR
in Kenya particularly Kenya says it will
not feel safe until its restore peace is
restored in Somalia not only Somalia
itself is unstable it is a source of
instability in the whole region what's
to do about that it's an instability in
the whole region simply because for a
very long time there hasn't been a
proper intervention that was done by the
international community and leaving
Somalis alone to solve these problems
this has caused a problem for not only
for Somalia but as well as for the
region this is now what one of the
things that we have started by having
the AMISOM forces coming in and changing
the it became a change again changer and
now slowly slowly we are gree gaining
our control of our territories and also
providing the kind of support that the
region needs in terms of security but
Kenya has threatened to close them up
camp the world's biggest refugee city on
June 9th Kenya and Somalia reached an
agreement on the repatriation of
refugees there are more than a million
Somali refugees in the camp alone they
are more than 300 thousand of 267 okay
300 where are you going to live what are
they going to live and work what are you
going to do with all these people when
they are arriving to Somalia first of
all these are Somalis and they have
every right to return back to their home
and this is something that we as a
government have to abide by
secondly we working with Kenya and to
come up with whether with you know will
you do I mean country around three
hundred four hundred thousand people are
coming back to your country what will
you do can I finish so we're working
with them on a tripartite agreement
where we're going to have a much more
gradual repatriation of all of the
Somalis over a period of one to three
years this is one second thing is we're
also trying to build the you know and
you know you know with the support of
the international community to build the
environment that to make it in conducive
for attorneys to come back to we're also
in one is that in areas that are Shabaab
controlled we're also taking an
offensive there to make sure that it is
possible for their for their attorneys
to return back to so these are some of
the things that we're going to do now
the other thing is when when it comes to
the livelihoods we are also working on
on a long term livelihoods program that
would allow return needs to come back
and they can make you know living out of
it and not you know coming back
I understood let's look at corruption it
is rampant in Somalia isn't it well it
is rampant because of the fact that
there were no systems and now with the
systems in place it is it is it is
reducing really because in its global
corruption perception index transparency
international ranks Somalia now at the
absolute bottom as the world's most
corrupt country tied with North Korea a
country can only be that corrupt if the
government itself is corrupt or turns a
blind eye to corruption I think what
transparency international does is that
they look at the at the other systems
and they don't look at you know figures
you know this is something that has been
also challenged and in terms of how they
do their ranking so they look at mainly
of the types of systems that are
available systems are not there in
Somalia so there is no way that you can
judge how many
how many officials were charged because
our interruption Court it's a criminal
act yeah but how many the officials were
charged but you need you also need to
have the evidence so if you have an
evidence if you're not know you have
making a try I know you have you have to
have you have to have the con to happen
under trial to be made and you have
enough cases for a judge to be judged
don't have in your country
yeah well there are only one or two or
three you don't know them you don't know
them you don't know who is corrupt in
your country well I mean you know you
cannot there is the whole principle of
you know innocent before innocent until
proven guilty make a case of that there
are the cases but the cases they will
come when they are they will come when
they are because last year Somalia owns
auditor-general this is a state
institution reported serious financial
irregularities in most government
ministries this is your own Auditor
General saying that not an external body
here again he's saying he irregularities
in most government ministries and you
are still looking who is response and
the thing is it for him to say that and
that is a statement that he made he had
to follow through and presented to the
prosecutor to the Attorney General and
find out that continue with the
prosecution if he hasn't done it then he
is at fault and it's not also a part of
the duty of the government it is the
part of the district oh did you bring
people to the court where you thought
that they are but yes remove that he has
to prove that and bring the case to
prove some no no they have to bring
bring the cases against those people so
if he doesn't why you didn't bring some
cases you don't know anybody was corrupt
in your ministry in other ministries
those that I know that are corrupt I
would have brought him but I don't I
mean the ones that I don't know I cannot
okay another example the legacy legacy
center for peace transparency says
extensive corruption Somali society
has been institutionalized become
customary and accepted as an informal
part of everyday life therefore the
public does not challenge the status quo
it's your duty to challenge that that is
true and we you know but the thing is
one thing that you also need to
understand and this is what a lot of
times you know and I kept on saying and
I had said it earlier comparing apples
to apples is is comparing apples orange
is a very see if you compare it to a
much more stable country like you know
into Somalia it is a problem so we going
through a structural change a cultural
change social changes that is happening
it is not something that can be done
over this is very that is it yes art is
very respected but to change it needs a
start
yeah but moment where you start for
example the start against corruption has
to live the starting the start we have
done is very it is very simple we have
set up with the international support a
public finance management that is that
is that's a good stuff we are setting up
the you know we the procurement system
it is ongoing the budget it is ongoing
reporting of the budget it is on
something else is ongoing elections some
areas do to hold elections this year
your government had four years to
prepare for this and yet you are failing
to live up to the vision of one-person
one-vote like in any other democracy how
do you explain the failure well I let me
tell you one thing and I'll give I'll
give you an example of us of my personal
I was a victim of a suicide attack so
when the attack happened
the problem was the case that came
afterwards and what happened was that I
was I was there and I was not able to
move they had to take me and put me on a
on an ambulance with no support with
nothing with a stretcher nothing on top
of that when I came back the question
that has always kind of was what is a
priority is it is the ambulance a
priority the you know
and the first eight are their priority
is it the doctor that is a priority so
Hospital rarity for elections all of
them are a priority know what I'm saying
that all of these are priorities so now
for the elections to happen what is the
priority security is a priority security
and elections are not contradictory the
elections is the will of the people and
you continue to protect with the army
how are you going to do how are you
going to vote you have to prepare that
phone how it is going to vote if you
need you need security you need what I
call demarcation of boundaries you need
a federal system to take into place you
need all of these all of that is what
what has been missing and it was very
difficult to do it within four years but
then let's let's discuss about something
else you need its judiciary judiciary a
system you say Somalis are in control of
the judiciary but last year the
president sacked the Judicial Service
commissioned independent analysts say
you basically have no independent
judiciary and that it's mostly left to
Sharia to tribal courts militant groups
military courts to dispense justice
including capital punishment but this is
one of the most important proves one of
the most important proof a legal system
of lawyers judges and it's not the thing
to do by tribal courts militant groups
and it's your president who sacked the
Judicial Service Commission first of all
the judicial we have passed what he
called an independent judicial committee
that was passed to the Parliament and
just to have them in place that is why
we have brought them that's why they
were sacked the reason why they were
sacked was to make were to pave way for
the you know the independent Judicial
Committee
okay now unfortunately we were not able
to pass through Parliament the two that
were and the two that were also part of
the one one was the Constitutional Court
and the other one was the Human Rights
no to be passed to be able to have the
full members the UN has has another view
on that but not only you are failing to
impose the rule of law you are failing
to educate your people Somalia has an
adult literacy rate of less than 32% how
can you build a state when only a third
of the population can read and write it
very simple increase that increase your
literacy rate and over the years that's
how it's been done look at Syria from
96% to going down so it's not something
that is a good sign do you with
stability to go okay do you increase
also another case only 42 percent of
school-age children Somalia are in
school one of the world
lowest enrollment rate only 1/3 of them
are girls that means 2/3 are boys why 10
years ago they were only 28% today there
are 42 percent so that shows you that
there is an increase and that will also
continue with the girls it has also
increased so it will it is something
that is in process there are cultural
problems that we face there's a problem
of accessibility there is a problem of
choosing parents choosing between the
girl boy or the girl or the Oddie
exactly the girl child or the boy child
which one will go to Zion are they are
they not equal no in societies like here
there they are in your society when it
comes to education sometimes it is not
it's another important issue for women
female genital mutilation an estimate 98
percent of Somali women girls are
subjected to it do you consider female
genital mutilation acceptable it is not
acceptable but the reality on the ground
is different we are dealing with people
people who are accustomed to this how
are you going to change this is the
right of the Sharia this is something
unbelievable that every girl I mean 98
percent this I don't want to challenge
the numbers but whatever I one thing I
can tell you girls
too much no no I know what I want I
don't want to challenge the numbers but
what I know is that there has been a
decrease in terms of of the girls like
the government doing it's even not a law
passed through the Parliament it's a
constitution there is a bill that is in
the past
it isn't it is in the it is in the
Parliament the bill is in the parliament
but it's going to be passed what is your
opinion about that do you think it has
to be stopped immediately it has to be
stopped immediately and it is it is
wrong of anyone going through that film
female genital mutilation thank you very
much to being with us in conflict so it
was a pleasure thank you